Por lo tanto, la posibilidad de explicar los misterios de la gravedad
y de descubrir las dimensiones extraespaciales...
tal vez ahora se dan una idea
de por qué miles de frikis de la física perdieron colectivamente la calma
ante la pequeña protuberancia de dos fotones.
Un descubrimiento de este tipo sería reescribir los libros de texto.
Pero recuerden,
nuestro mensaje como experimentadores
que hacían este trabajo en el momento,
fue muy claro:
necesitamos más datos.
Con más datos,
la pequeña protuberancia bien podría convertirse en un premio Nobel en ciernes,
(Risas)
O los datos adicionales deberán rellenar el espacio alrededor de la protuberancia
y convertirla en una línea agradable y suave.
Así que tomamos más datos,
y cinco veces más datos, varios meses después,
nuestra pequeña protuberancia
se había convertido en una línea suave.
La noticia informó una "gran decepción" de "esperanzas marchitas,"
y de "la tristeza de los físicos de partículas".
Teniendo en cuenta el tono de la cobertura,
se podría pensar que habíamos decidido cerrar el colisionador y volver a casa.
(Risas)
Pero eso no es lo que hicimos.
¿Pero por qué no?
Es decir, si no he descubierto una partícula, y no lo hice,
si no he descubierto una partícula, ¿por qué estoy aquí hablando con Uds.?
¿Por qué no se me cae la cara de vergüenza
y vuelvo a casa?
Los físicos de partículas somos exploradores.
Y mucho de lo que hacemos es cartografiar.
Lo pondré de esta manera: olvídense del colisionador por un segundo.
Imaginen que son exploradores espaciales que llegan a un planeta distante,
a la búsqueda de extraterrestres.
¿Cuál es su primera tarea?
Para orbitar de inmediato el planeta, aterrizar, echar un vistazo alrededor
en busca de signos evidentes de la vida,
e informar a la base.
Esa es la etapa que estamos ahora.
Echamos un primer vistazo en el colisionador
buscando partículas nuevas, grandes, obviamente detectables,
y podemos informar que no hay ninguna.
Vimos una protuberancia extraña de aspecto raro en una montaña lejana,
pero al acercarnos, vimos que era una roca.
Pero entonces, ¿qué hacemos? ¿Nos damos por vencidos y nos vamos?
Por supuesto que no.
Seríamos científicos terribles si nos rindiéramos.
No, pasamos las siguientes dos décadas explorando,
cartografiando el territorio,
tamizando la arena con un instrumento fino,
mirando debajo de cada piedra,
perforando la superficie.
Nuevas partículas pueden mostrar ya sea de inmediato
protuberancias grandes, evidentes,
o pueden revelarse tras años de toma de datos.
La humanidad acaba de comenzar su exploración con el colisionador,
en este coloso de alta energía, y tenemos mucho que hacer.
Pero ¿y si, incluso tras 10 o 20 años, seguimos sin encontrar nuevas partículas?
Construimos una máquina más grande.
(Risas)
Buscamos con energías mayores.
Buscamos con altas energías.
Están planeadas para un túnel de 100 km
que colisionará partículas a 10 veces la energía del LHC.
No decidimos donde la naturaleza coloca nuevas partículas.
Solo decidimos seguir explorando.
Pero ¿y si, incluso tras construir un túnel de 100 km
o un túnel de 500 km
o un colisionador de 10 000 km que flote en el espacio
entre la Tierra y la luna,
seguimos sin encontrar nuevas partículas?
Entonces, tal vez estamos explorando mal la física de partículas.
(Risas)
Tal vez tenemos que volver a pensar las cosas.
Tal vez necesitamos más recursos, tecnología, experiencia,
que lo que tenemos actualmente.
Ya usamos técnicas de aprendizaje automático y de inteligencia artificial
en algunas partes del colisionador,
pero imaginen el diseño de un experimento de física de partículas
que usa algoritmos sofisticados
que podrían autoaprender para descubrir un gravitón hiperdimensional.
¿Pero y si...?
¿Qué pasa si, en última instancia,
la inteligencia artificial no nos ayuda a responder nuestras preguntas?
¿Y si estas preguntas durante siglos no resueltas,
no tuvieran respuestas en un futuro inmediato?
¿Y si las cosas que me molestaban desde niño
están destinadas a no tener respuestas en el transcurso de mi vida?
Entonces...
eso será aún más fascinante.
Nos veremos obligados a pensar en formas completamente nuevas.
Tendremos que volver a nuestras suposiciones,
y determinar si hay un defecto en alguna parte.
Y necesitaremos para animar a más gente unirnos en el estudio de la ciencia
ya que necesitamos una mirada nueva sobre estos problemas centenarios.
No tengo las respuestas y aún estoy en busca de ellas.
Pero alguien, tal vez ella está en la escuela en este momento,
tal vez ella ni siquiera ha nacido todavía,
podría finalmente guiarnos para ver la física de forma completamente nueva,
e indicarnos que tal vez estamos haciendo las preguntas equivocadas.
Lo que no sería el fin de la física,
sino el comienzo de una novela.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)